officials say the flooding began in late
june
after heavy rains in the northern parts
of bangladesh and neighbouring india
the countries share over 50 rivers while
flooding takes place
almost every year during the monsoon
season this year's have been
particularly bad
the situation in bangladesh has become
dire for many
especially farmers who depend on their
livestock
the flood water is constantly rising
neither we nor our cattle could go out
we need a small boat to do so
we're having problems with food too the
cooking ovens have been flooded
even our beds are under water
the floods have destroyed crops and
driven people in several impoverished
regions from their homes
well over a million people are on the
move looking for safety
our homesteads have been flooded we had
a small road out here
but it got destroyed last night so we're
trying to salvage all our crops
like rice and corn and other goods
the country's flood forecasting center
has warned that the situation could
worsen still
with major rivers expected to rise even
further in the coming days
it's important to remember that
bangladesh is also hosting about a
million
rohingya refugees from neighboring
myanmar
for more let's talk to mahimuaz in cox
bazaar that's where
the main refugee camp is he's the
director for
save the children in that area mr noah's
can you tell us more about the current
situation there
yes thank you actually uh camp is not a
good place uh for
for living particularly for children and
women during this heavy monsoon and you
mentioned that
more than one million people are living
there in
bamboo and turkey made very temporary
uh and with weight floor uh temporary
housings which
is not at all healthy uh we were
discussing
this with the mother of two children
from the tecna
and she was mentioning that she didn't
she she doesn't like to
to live here she is in fear of that her
child her children will be sick and she
is also fear of landslide
and also flooding and you know that
the the situation in the camp the the
the physical condition is is very uh
is not suitable uh the heavy mud
landslides
water logging and flash floods actually
all all of them
are not good good good to live here
what's the government doing to help is
the bangladeshi government
doing enough
bangladesh government is supporting um
the
northern part where the floods is hit
but in southern part in wrong
in um in rohingya camp uh the
humanitarian agencies are working with
the coordination of bangladesh
government
so bangladesh government is offering uh
the coordination and administrative
support
but um here is the hamilton worker like
say the children and other agencies
uh are supporting and our staffs are
actually working tirelessly
to get the information if any facilities
or any houses are get damaged
and to repair so that facilities can
continue
and also they are offering food as part
of the rapid response
so that they are not hungry due to the
landslide or
or household damage and uh within this
month uh starting this monsoon 95
incident happened for the
uh for alone for for landslides across
the camp area which
is impacted more than seventy thousand
individuals
across the camp which is a huge number
of who affected
due to monsoon mahindra is from cox
bazaar in bangladesh
thank you very much you're most welcome
thank you